[Música]
momento de actualizar la información
económica en directo América por ello le
doy la bienvenida nuevamente a mi
compañero Juan Pablo locumi Juan Pablo
qué tal empezamos con Estados Unidos
porque el presidente Joe biden anunció
la liberación de reservas de energía
estratégicas para el país cuáles son y
por qué lo hizo cuéntenos Así es Andrés
pues ayer conocimos que el presidente
decidió liberar 15 millones de barriles
de petróleo de las reservas estratégicas
del país a tres semanas de las
elecciones de medio mandato byden busca
que el precio del combustible disminuya
ya que esta ha sido una de las
situaciones que ha golpeado los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses la
decisión también llega luego de que la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo más Rusia anunciaran a
principios de este mes que reducirán la
producción mundial de petróleo en dos
millones de barriles diarios con la poca
cantidad de barriles disponibles en el
mercado y con la demanda igual de alta
el precio del combustible se ha
disparado byden Busca que haya más
petróleo disponible y en repetidas
ocasiones le ha llamado la atención a
las empresas productoras el presidente
también anunció una financiación de
2.800 millones de dólares para la
producción de baterías para vehículos
eléctricos Esto fue lo que dijo
mi mensaje para las compañías
energéticas estadounidenses es este no
deben usar sus ganancias para recomprar
acciones o pagar dividendos No ahora no
Mientras la guerra esté en su apogeo
deben usar estas ganancias récords para
aumentar la producción y la refinación
hoy estoy anunciando un plan para llenar
la reserva estratégica de petróleo en
los próximos años con beneficios para
los contribuyentes el gobierno de
Estados Unidos comparará hidrocarburo
para llenar las reservas estratégicas de
petróleo cuando los precios bajen a 70
dólares por barril Juan Pablo Hablamos
ahora de Colombia porque el
fortalecimiento del dólar ha dicho que
la moneda local Se devalúe drásticamente
Así es que el fortalecimiento del dólar
en Colombia es 2,3 veces mayor frente a
las monedas las otras monedas de América
Latina este miércoles un dólar llegó a
costar
4.840 pesos colombianos el
encarecimiento del billete verde empezó
de manera consecutiva en el país desde
la el presidente Gustavo Petro al poder
los empresarios sobre todo el sector de
hidrocarburos se han sentido temerosos
con las recientes propuestas del
mandatario y han recortado sus
inversiones la depreciación promedio de
las monedas de América Latina es del
5,4%, mientras en Colombia la
depreciación ha alcanzado el
12,8%. al respecto funcionarios del
gobierno se pronunciaron vamos a hacer
una política macroeconómica responsable
vamos a cumplir la regla fiscal no haber
control de cambios vamos a diversificar
exportaciones el tema de
digamos de exploración de petróleo y gas
es un tema que todavía estamos haciendo
los ejercicios para ver qué se necesitan
esa materia Juan Pablo actualizamos
ahora el tema de las refinerías en
Francia y la escasez de combustible en
ese país que es lo último pues la
refinerías de algunas regiones del país
anunciaron que retoman funciones Ese es
el caso de al oeste de Francia luego de
unas votaciones los trabajadores
decidieron que volverán a sus labores al
menos en la refinería total Energy
energes de esa comuna francesa sin
embargo en el país el 22,8% de las
estaciones de servicio todavía
presentaban escasez de gasolina o diesel
entre el martes y este miércoles
nos parece obvio que la dirección
general quiere jugar a la política con
base a las requisas ilegales que hizo el
Gobierno de born
por lo que esto nos lleva hoy asumir
nuestras responsabilidades y anunciar
claramente el cese del movimiento con
respecto a la refinería de Dong
puedo anunciarles hoy que el movimiento
en la refinería de facing obviamente
continuará hasta que tengamos otra
reunión de negociación para que puedan
seguir progresando las cosas
en todos los momentos de conocer Los
indicadores Andrés pues empezamos con
Wall Street porque interrumpió los dos
días de las ganancias que veníamos
reportando y cerró Este miércoles con
medidas las decisiones de los
inversionistas estuvieron basadas en los
informes del tercer trimestre de varias
empresas ya que fueron drásticos las
bolsas europeas cerraron también en rojo
luego del fortalecimiento del dólar Pues
por primera vez en 20 años la moneda
estadounidense llegó a valer más que el
euro los informes de la inflación de la
eurozona también marcaron las decisiones
bursátiles nuestra región cerró en
terreno mixto la bolsa de Sao Paulo tuvo
un alza de
0,46%, luego de conocerse el anuncio del
presidente biden de la activación de las
reservas petroleras que recién acabamos
de hablar pues la petrolera estatal
petrobras se verá beneficiada con esta
medida y nuestra cifra del día 20 mil
euros costará el auto eléctrico peso
pluma de Francia hecho en burdeos sin
contar las ayudas estatales que da el
gobierno francés como el bono ecológico
se espera que el auto ultraliviano sea
comercializado en 2024 por tan solo
pesar 900 kilos se espera también que
este en particular consuma más o menos
Juan Pablo lukumi con la información
económica Gracias seguimos con más aquí
en directo América